und ich hoffe auf zusatzpunkt drei
beratungen des antrags der fraktionen
der spd cdu/csu bündnis 90/die grünen
und fdp mit dem titel frieden und
freiheit in europa verteidigen
umfassende unterstützung für die ukraine
wir werden nachher über diesen antrag
namentlich abstimmen
ich eröffne die aussprache und gebe das
wort für bündnis 90 die grünen der
kollegin britta haßelmann
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen seit dem 24
februar ist unsere welt eine andere
mitten in europa tobt ein furchtbarer
krieg
völkerrechtswidrig mit kriegsverbrechen
und an brutalität und grausamkeit die
wir jeden tag erleben kaum vorstellbar
dieser angriffskrieg bricht in
eklatanter weise mit dem
internationalen recht auf dass sich die
weltgemeinschaft gemeinsam verständigt
hat ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht
seit dem 24
2 beginnt jeder morgen mit neuen
schrecklichen nachrichten aus der
ukraine und beginnt jeder tag mit trauer
mit schmerz mit fassungslosigkeit über
das ausmaß der zerstörung über das leid
von menschen über tod über kinder auf
der flucht die bilder von und
vorstellung von menschen die durften in
bunkern
hausen ermordete zivilistinnen und
zivilisten tote soldaten und
vergewaltigung als kriegswaffe gegen
frauen inzwischen systematisch
eingesetzt der krieg zerstört unsere
europäische friedens- und sicherheitsrat
nung und ist ein angriff auf unsere
werte von freiheit von demokratie und
selbstbestimmung
wir alle
diesen krieg aufs schärfste und die
russische regierung muss alle
kampfhandlungen
unverzüglich einstellen
seit zwei monaten
arbeiten wir
ununterbrochen
und mit nachdruck daran hier im
parlament in der bundesregierung mit
unseren europäischen partnern in g7 mit
der weltgemeinschaft der internationalen
staatengemeinschaft
ununterbrochen daran wie können wir
hilfe und unterstützung bieten dazu
gehört finanzielle unterstützung
wirtschaftliche unterstützung
humanitäre unterstützung
und auf die unterstützung mit waffen wir
ringen
seit diesem tag um ehrliche antworten
wir wägen ab wir zweifeln
ja und wir hadern
aber und wir entscheiden
und das ist am ende das was zählt
niemand weiß heute genau
was wir in diesen meine damen und herren
und mich beruhigen die die alle heute
schon ganz genau wissen was gestern und
übermorgen zu tun ist ich finde es
wichtig zum ausdruck zu bringen
wie schwer die situation ist und wie
darum gerungen werden muss was die
richtigen antworten sind wir haben
inzwischen fünf harte sanktionspaket
gegen russland und die russische führung
vereinbart wichtig und notwendig alles
getragen im europäischen kontext der
nato der weltgemeinschaft
wir tun alles um so schnell wie möglich
aus dieser wahnsinnig zementierten
abhängigkeit fossile energien in die uns
die fehlentscheidung der letzten jahren
gebracht haben rauszukommen auch das ist
wichtig und notwendig und wir sind bei
allem was wir tun vom festen grundsatz
geleitet dass die ukraine nach der
charta der vereinten nationen ein
uneingeschränktes recht auf
selbstverteidigung hat wir nehmen unsere
aufgabe verantwortungsvoll war
einerseits nicht kriegspartei zu werden
und das ist die erklärte absicht nicht
nur deutschland sondern aller
europäischen partnerinnen und partner
und andererseits die ukraine nicht
schutzlos diesem aggressor putin
auszuliefern liefern und hier genau
steht unsere verantwortung im
spannungsfeld immer wieder jeden tag
aufs neue zu entscheiden was ist
notwendig zu tun um die ukraine in ihrem
recht auf selbstverteidigung zu
unterstützen meine damen und herren und
da
deshalb ist es auch wichtig und
notwendig dass wir jetzt neben der
finanziellen humanitären und
waffenlieferungen die wir schon direkt
im anschluss getroffen haben nachdem
angriffs kriegsbeginn jetzt auch den
ringtausch schwerer waffen und die
massive finanzielle unterstützung der
ukraine für direkte waffenkäufe und die
lieferung eigener schwerer waffen da wo
es möglich ist zu prüfen in aller
sorgfalt und dann auch zu entscheiden so
wie wir das jetzt getan haben und in
diesem antrag noch einmal gemeinsam
bekräftigen die ukraine kann sich auf
unsere unterstützung verlassen
meine damen und herren es freut mich
dass wir dieses signal vom gemeinsamen
von der union abgeben auch dass an
dieser stelle ganz eindeutig gesagt in
richtung der cdu csu den ein wichtiges
signal in dieser krisenzeit ist nach
innen und nach außen das demokratinnen
und demokraten hier in diesem haus an
dieser stelle zusammen stehen und dafür
bin ich dankbar dass der bundesregierung
meine damen und herren und unser
gemeinsamer antrag heute hier im
parlament
sind ein starkes signal an die ukraine
bitte meine damen und herren verstehen
sie es als solches und es ist auch ein
klares signal an die menschen hier im
land die voller sorge auf das leid die
zerstörung und die entwicklung dieses
krieges schauen vielen dank
für die unionsfraktion ad aisch das wort
dem kollegen friedrich merz
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
diesen jungs und mädels muss ich mal
sagen
weil ich nicht tue was ihr wollt deshalb
führe ich
so hat sich der bundeskanzler einige
tage vor ostern in einem
rundfunkinterview auf die frage ein
gelassen ob er und wie er denn in diesem
land führen mit jungs und mädels waren
dabei offenbar die drei
ausschussvorsitzenden gemeint die eine
reise in die west kleine unternommen
hatten mal ganz unabhängig davon wer das
war mitglieder des deutschen bundestages
herablassend mit jungs und mädels zu
bezeichnen das ist auch für einen
bundeskanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland
meine damen und herren einfach nur das
gegenteil von dem zu tun was mitglieder
des deutschen bundestages für richtig
halten ist auch kein ausdruck vom
führung könnte
dieser sprachgebrauch ist eher ein
zeichen von unsicherheit und von
schwäche der bundeskanzler der
bundeskanzler hat über wochen die
diskussion über die frage ob der ukraine
der nun waffen geliefert werden sollten
oder nicht hingehalten offengelassen
ausweichend beantwortet ich erinnere nur
an die
regierungsbefragung die wir vor drei
wochen hier hatten der bundeskanzler hat
alle fragen beantwortet die ihm nicht
gestellt worden sind und keine einzige
frage von denen beantwortet die ihm
gestellt hat meine damen
das ist nicht besonnenheit wie sie es in
den ampel fraktionen versuchen in den
letzten tagen zu erklären das ist zögern
das ist zaudern und das ist
ängstlichkeit nun regen sich darüber auf
dass
wir hier das im plenum ansprechen aber
meine damen und herren das problem für
den bundeskanzler war und ist nicht die
opposition das problem für den
bundeskanzler war und ist bis zum
heutigen tag die kritik aus den eigenen
reihen
und dabei waren dabei waren worte wie
führungsschwäche und kommunikations
desaster noch harmlose formulierungen
politische hütchen spiele sind dem
bundeskanzler vorgeworfen worden bis hin
zu der offenen frage ob er denn seinem
amt noch gewachsen sei ich will es dabei
bewenden lassen es ist
gewiss nicht also wenn sie wenn sie
staatspolitische verantwortung der
opposition nur so verstehen dass wir
ihnen in allem was sie hier vorliegen
und vorschlagen kritiklos zustimmen dann
ist das ein großer irrtum meine damen
und herren und wir
wir erlauben uns hier schon diese
fertigt die da geäußert aufzunehmen und
zum gegenstand einer parlamentarischen
diskussion zu machen meine damen und
herren und es ist trotzdem gut dass wir
heute gemeinsam den versuch unternehmen
einen entschließungsantrag zu
verabschieden der sich umfassend mit der
hilfe für die ukraine befasst wenn die
bundesregierung in wenn die
bundesregierung in den letzten tagen und
wochen zu diesen fragen eine klare und
einvernehmliche haltung eingenommen
hätte und wenn der bundeskanzler dies
hier klar und unmissverständlich gesagt
hätte dann wäre weder der antrag
notwendig gewesen noch diese ganze
debatte heute morgen
und in ein so viel und wenn hier in der
letzten woche nicht einen antrag
vorgelegt hätten dann wären sie doch nie
auf den gedanken gekommen nun ihrerseits
tätig zu werden und einen solchen anlass
den deutschen bundestag foto hjm
wir führen wir eine wir führen hier eine
wichtige diskussion und wir nehmen hier
auch unsere verantwortung in dieser
diskussion war und ich will deswegen
ich will ihnen nochmal auch zu der
debatte von gestern ihr etwas sagen wir
hatten gestern die diskussion über das
100 milliarden programm für die
bundeswehr und dem dazu vorgeschlagene
text der änderung des grundgesetzes
meine damen und herren wir haben die
sechs punkte die für uns wichtig sind
wenn wir dem denn dann zustimmen sollen
genannt ich sage ihnen nochmal nehmen
sie das bitte nicht auf die leichte
schulter wir sind grundsätzlich bereit
mit ihnen einen solchen weg zu gehen
aber wir lassen uns auch nicht einfach
nur so zur zustimmung auf fordern wir
haben einige punkte genannt und ich will
es hier an dieser stelle noch einmal
sehr deutlich wiederholen unsere
zustimmung ist auch davon abhängig dass
wir in wenigen jahren nicht wieder da
stehen wo wir heute stehen nämlich mit
einer unterfinanzierten bundeswehr und
deswegen wollte deswegen sollen das
leben wollen dass der kunde das der
einzelplan 14 für die verteidigung
kontinuierlich aufwächst und nicht die
einmalig ein bestimmter betrag zur
verfügung gestellt wird wir wollen die
beschaffungs systematik ändern übrigens
der bundeskanzler war begeistert als wir
ihm das vorgeschlagen haben dass wir an
diesem beschaffungs system etwas ändern
wollen dann machen wir es doch jetzt
gemeinsam und norwegen und ketten ziehen
sie doch nicht in der opposition herum
gewesen diese beiden punkte nennen wir
haben hier noch einen ziemlich langen
weg wir haben hier noch einen ziemlich
langen weg vor uns und es sind dem
vorschlag den der bundeskanzler vor acht
wochen unternommen wertvolle zeit
verstrichen wir sind zu keinem dieser
punkte bisher überein gekommen
geschweige denn dass wir hier ein
gemeinsames gesamt voraus die formuliert
und aufgeschrieben haben wir sind noch
ziemlich weit entfernt von einer
einigung meine damen und herren
mit dem entschließungsantrag des
heutigen tages sind wir dann und weise
einen schritt weiter richtigerweise
enthält dieser text nicht nur
bewertungen und einschätzungen zu
waffenlieferungen an die richtigerweise
auch wir wissen dass waffengewalt in
einer solchen auseinandersetzung immer
nur das letzte mittel sein darf und
letztendlich auch das eingeständnis des
scheiterns von diplomatie und der suche
nach politischen lösungen umfasst das
ist so aber an dieser stelle stehen wir
seit dem 24 februar 2022 und ich will es
mal mit diesen worten deutlich sagen
niemand von uns befürwortet leichtfertig
den einsatz militärischer gewalt niemand
wir alle wissen dass mit dem einsatz von
waffen
also diese zwischenrufe verstehe ich nun
wirklich überhaupt nicht wenn wir hier
eine wenn wir hier eine gewissenhafte
diskussion führen wollen und bei einem
solchen satz von ihnen solche solche
zwischenrufe kommen dann frage ich mich
wie ernst sie eigentlich wirklich die
bereitschaft hier vortragen mit uns zu
einer gemeinsamen lösung in diesen
schwierigen fall
wir haben doch alle diese wir haben doch
alle diese schrecklichen bilder vor
augen und sie beschweren uns doch jeden
tag die bilder dieser
menschenrechtsverletzung die bilder aus
diesen aus diesem kraftwerk aus diesem
stahlwerk da einmal in mario pohl das
sind doch furchtbare bilder aber gerade
weil wir diese bilder vor augen haben
müssen wir doch heute sagen einem
aggressor wie putin und seine
machtapparat muss man dann in einer
solchen situation auch als ultima ratio
mit militärischer gewalt begegnen es
geht nicht anders in einer solchen
situation
das bestreitet niemand aber wir müssen
doch gemeinsam auch nach draußen hin
erklären warum wir heute zu einem
solchen entschließungsantrag hier
gemeinsam kommen und wenn sie das schon
vor einigen wochen getan hätten noch mal
dann brauchten wir es doch heute
gemeinsam nicht zu tun an der stelle
stehen wir doch heute wenn die op und
ihre mutige armee das nicht täten und
wenn dir der ukraine dabei nicht helfen
würden dann wird diese unterlassene
hilfe wie schon in der vergangenheit als
schwäche und als zögerlichkeit ausgelegt
und dann wird es nach der ukraine
weitere länder und weitere regionen
geben die von diesem regime bedroht
meine damen genießen zusammen in diesem
zusammenhang ist der hinweis des
bundeskanzlers dass unsere deutschen
waffen möglicherweise einen dritten
weltkrieg auslösen würden ebenso
unverantwortlich wie aus unserer eigenen
historischen erfahrung heraus falsch und
irreführend
wer hinweise zu verantworten
der hinweis ist unverantwortlich denn er
lässt ja nur den schluss zu dass aus der
sicht des bundeskanzlers alle anderen
länder die mehr für die ukraine tun als
wir und davon gibt es viele die
kriegsgefahr in europa erhöhen meine
damen und herren das ist doch eine
geradezu groteske umkehrung von ursache
und verantwortung für diesen krieg eine
professur
oder überfahren
was auch wenn hier erst richtung spd
oder warum sollten gerade deutsche
waffen diese wirkung haben alle anderen
aber nicht auf meine damen und herren
der historie der hinweis ist auch
historisch falsch weil doch gerade wir
wissen dass besänftigung und
beschwichtigung in der internationalen
sprache der politik heißt das
achievement die ausweitung einer
aggression überhaupt erst möglich macht
und deshalb ist es gut deshalb ist es
gut dass wir heute mit diesem
gemeinsamen antrag und der
beschlussfassung darüber klarheit
schaffen die deutsche bundesregierung
kann sich ab heute auf ein breites
zustimmendes votum des deutschen
bundestages stützen und der ukraine die
waffen liefern die sie braucht und die
wir dann auch zur verfügung stellen
können und deswegen will ich es
abschließend sagt und da habe ich
irgendwelche abschließend sagen ich will
mich ausdrücklich bedanken bei den
fraktionen der spd der grünen und der
fdp und bei ihren jeweiligen
vorsitzenden dass wir in den letzten
tagen zu dieser gemeinsamen haltung hier
auch gefunden haben die arbeit an den
texten und die vielen gespräche die wir
in den letzten tagen dazu geführt haben
meine damen und herren hat sich gelohnt
herzlichen dank
das klingt wer hat das wort für die spd
fraktion
warum
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
seit über zwei monaten führt wladimir
putin einen brutalen angriffskrieg gegen
die ukraine täglich sehen wir das leid
dass putin und seine vasallen über die
menschen im land bringen gezielte tötung
von zivilisten die bombardierung von
krankenhäusern von schulen von
kindergärten
wladimir putin trägt die verantwortung
für diesen krieg er wird als
kriegsverbrechern die geschichte
eingehen und wir werden alles daran
setzen dass er vor den zuständigen
gerichten dieser welt für diesen
brutalen krieg zur verantwortung gezogen
es ist gut
es ist gut dass wir heute hier im
parlament ein eindeutiges ein um
missverständnisse
unmissverständliches signal aus der
mitte des deutschen bundestages setzen
putin muss diesen völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg beenden wir stehen an der
seite derjenigen die mutig und tapfer in
der ukraine kämpfen wir stehen an der
seite der ukraine das machen wir mit
diesem gemeinsamen antrag gold
herr merz mir war wichtig diesen punkt
am anfang meiner rede zu nehmen bei
ihnen
bei jedem hat es bei ihnen hat es fünf
minuten gedauert bis sie zum ersten mal
etwas zum krieg und zum leiden der
menschen in der ukraine gesagt habe und
ich habe hier eigentlich auf meinem
zettel draufstehen ich habe hier
eigentlich auf meinem zettel draufstehen
dank an die union weil er merz und ich
muss ihnen das in aller emotionalität
auch sagen das hätte heute eine
staatspolitische rede von ihnen werden
können es ist aber es ist eine
parteipolitische rede geworden wir haben
sie haben zu ihren eigenen leuten
gesprochen und ich will ihnen sagen herr
merz ich bin dankbar dafür dass wir
einen gemeinsamen antrag auf den weg
gebracht haben einen dank an die vier
fraktionen und die vorsitzenden
aber hier ist kein platz für
parteipolitische profilierung und ich
will dass
ich will dass
dann merkte ich will dass meine eigenen
geschichte beschreiben ich bin 2009 in
dieses parlament gekommen die spd ist
damals in die opposition gegangen das
war schwierig für uns weil wir lange
regiert wir haben eine schwarz gelbe
regierung erlebt die nicht immer
harmonisch wochen und trotzdem haben wir
als spd damals bei den großen
internationalen fragen die abgestimmt
wurden nach dem prinzip gehandelt erst
das land dann die partei erinnern sie
sich erinnern sie sich herr merz
erinnern sie sich an das cartwright das
gefecht das erste mal dass deutsche
soldaten im ausland gefallen sind
trotzdem hat die spd am afghanistan
mandat festgehalten hat das klare
bekenntnis zur bundeswehr abgegeben
erinnern sie sich an die großen debatten
über die schutzschirme für griechenland
für spanien der euro rettungsschirm wir
hätten uns das einfach machen können
aber wir haben damals nie gegen die
regierung bestimmt lieber herr merz und
ich habe mir sorgen gemacht die letzten
tage um die union als sie kritisiert
haben als sie kritisiert haben als sie
kritisiert haben dass olaf scholz nach
japan fährt das olaf scholz sich mit
einem der wichtigsten westlichen
verbündeten trifft da ich mich gefragt
was ist nur aus der union von angela
merkel geworden was passiert da gerade
in
wie bayer märz
lieber im märz diejenigen die am antrag
mitgeschrieben haben die haben nach dem
prinzip gehandelt erst das land dann die
partei und ich hätte mir gewünscht dass
diejenigen die ihre rede geschrieben
haben auch nach diesem grundsatz die
räder aufgeschrieben aber
zur sache
zur sache und ich will ein paar sätze
ein paar sätze zu diesem antrag auf
sagen weil es mir weil es mir wirklich
wichtig dieser antrag stützt das handeln
der bundesregierung diese regierung
handelt sie liefert sie führt und ich
will dass an dieser stelle auch sagen
weil antragsberatung
antragsberatung auch einen moment sind
wo man mal danke sagen kann die
vertreterinnen und vertretern der
bundesregierung haben entscheidungen zu
treffen von einer reichweite für die
nächsten 10 15 20 jahre von einer
tragweite die über leben und tod geht es
sind entscheidungen die man sich nicht
einfach macht in der regierung und ich
will stellvertretend hier nancy faeser
christian lindner annalena baerbock
christine lambrecht robert habeck und
vor allem bundeskanzler olaf scholz
danken für das was wir in den letzten
wochen an guter führung durch die
bundesregierung gemeinsame erlebt
und weil ich
und weil ich in den letzten tagen ja
viele bewertungen der bundesregierung
gelesen habe bin ich sicher empfehle mal
die aktuelle ausgabe der times da kriegt
man mal ein überblick auch wie
deutschlands rolle in der welt gesehen
wird lassen sie uns mal noch die fakten
schauen fakt eins deutschland hat mit
den partnern sanktionen vorbereitet und
setzt diese massiv durch selten gab es
ein so großes umfassendes sanktionspaket
wie jetzt gegen russland russland wird
ökonomisch abgekoppelt von den
internationalen märkten und wird das
über einen langen zeitraum bitter zu
spüren bekommen was die konsequenzen
dieser sanktionen sind fakt 2
deutschland reduziert die abhängigkeit
von russischem gas und russischem öl und
das tun wir in einem größeren tempo als
im koalitionsvertrag schon angelegt war
und ich bin dankbar dafür dass wir das
gemeinsam jetzt sind aller
entschiedenheit auch täglich tun fakten
nummer drei ist dass wir eingebettet in
die internationale kooperation agieren
der westen war lange nicht mehr so
geeint und so stark wie jetzt die nato
die europäische union und sagt ja auch
da müssen wir was draus machen wir
können nicht nur zusammen kommen weil
putin und treibt sondern wir brauchen
jetzt eine transatlantische agenda für
die zukunft wir brauchen jetzt eine
starke europäische union das ist ein
geschenk was da ist aber es ist das
handeln der bund
und ja deutschland liefert waffen diese
bundesregierung hat mit einem prinzip
gebrochen das über jahrzehnte in
deutschland galt wir liefern seit dem
beginn des krieges und wir sind jeden
tag einen schritt weiter gegangen in der
qualität in der quantität dessen was wir
tun aber wir hatten auch hier prinzipien
und in dieser kontinuität stehen auch
die entscheidung der letzten tage wir
haben gesagt wir stimmen uns ab mit den
internationalen partnern wir haben
gesagt wir gefährden nicht die eigene
landes und bündnisverteidigung und wir
haben gesagt dass wir selbst nicht zur
kriegspartei werden alles das tut die
bundesregierung und ich bin dankbar
dafür und das ist mein letzter punkt der
nicht ansprechen will ich bin dankbar
dafür dass wir eine regierung haben die
weiß dass sie konsequent und schnell
entscheiden ist die aber nichts herr
merz sowie das manchmal bei ihnen der
eindruck ist morgens aufwacht und
überlegt was können wir heute tun gerade
in diesen zeiten gerade in zeiten von
leben und tod von krieg und frieden geht
es darum dass man grundüberzeugung und
prinzipien hat und die auch in einer
zeitenwende nicht über den haufen wirft
liebe
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
trotz aller parteipolitische differenzen
will ich dass sie am ende noch einmal
betone es ist richtig und wichtig dass
es hier aus der mitte des parlamentes
ein klares signal an wladimir putin ein
klares signal an die menschen in der
ukraine gibt dass wir auf der richtigen
seite der geschichte als deutscher
bundestag stehen aber ich sage ihnen
auch ein kleingeist eine
kleinkariertheit wie sie manches mal
gerade erlebt wird in der politischen
debatte das bringt uns nicht weiter wir
haben schwierige entscheidungen vor uns
beispielsweise mit dem sondervermögen
und herr merz das ist mein letzter
appell machen sie deutlich dass sie an
der seite der soldatinnen und soldaten
stehen machen sie deutlich meinem leben
machen sie deutlich dass sie das im 16
gefühlte verteidigungsministerium dass
sie bereit sind diese fehler zu
korrigieren und mit der ampel gemeinsam
daran arbeiten dass wir die bundeswehr
ausstatten das wäre ein richtiges signal
aus der union viele frisuren
timo boll hat das wort für die fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe landsleute
vor nunmehr über zwei monaten hat
russland die ukraine angegriffen und wir
haben wieder krieg in europa
noch zu beginn haben wir alle hier in
diesem hohen haus gehofft dass der
konflikt schnell beendet sein wird und
die bevölkerung in der ukraine wieder in
ruhe leben kann leider kam es anders die
fraktion gedenkt aller kriegstoten und
trauert mit den hinterbliebenen
[Applaus]
der neue krieg in europa stellt uns alle
vor eine schwierige situation und
entscheidung letztlich werden alte
wunden aufgerissen und überkommene
denkmuster bedient aber gerade für ein
friedliches zusammenleben müssen wir die
ideologischen scheuklappen absetzen und
uns der diskussion im eigenen land
stellen ich finde es ganz dem
unentschuldbar dass bundeskanzler olaf
scholz heute an so einem wichtigen tag
hier nicht anwesend ist bislang stand
der bereits zu seinem wort dass waffen
keine lösung sind und heute bringen die
koalition und die unionsfraktion einen
gemeinsamen antrag ein der den ukraine
krieg verlängern wird und unser
kriegsparteien ein part number geführten
krieg machen könnte wer die kollegen wir
streiten über die zukunft deutschlands
es geht um krieg und frieden auch in
mitteleuropa und herr scholz reis der
kirschblüte nach japan und nein auch
reisepläne kann man ändern erinnern sie
sich der bundeskanzler ließ
außenministerin berbalk vorfristig nach
berlin zurückkehren um für die
impfpflicht abzustimmen und da sieht man
eigentlich
die prioritäten dieses bundeskanzlers wo
sind die und alle die immer davon
sprechen aus der geschichte gelernt zu
haben sind heute die ersten die uns
aktiven ein krieg hineinziehen wollen
und genau das sagt und bezeichnet diese
vorliegende antrag er liest sich wie die
beitritts begründung zu einem krieg vom
duktus erinnert er an die dunkelsten
zeiten
und ich muss ich hier noch mal deutlich
sagen ich muss hier noch mal deutlich
sagen wir sind uns nicht im krieg mit
russland oder irgendeinem land und die
große mehrheit der deutschen bevölkerung
möchte nicht in diesem krieg und an
diesem krieg beteiligt werden
und deswegen muss man fragen welchen
zweck verfolgen sie die ukraine gehört
nicht der nato an auch nicht der eu und
ist ebenso ein souveräner staaten
europas wie russland es liegt im
deutschen interesse auch zukünftig zu
beiden staaten ein gutes verhältnis zu
unterhalten politisch wirtschaftlich und
kulturell
und tun mit der entscheidung der
bundesregierung die panzer an die
ukraine zu liefern wurde die position
deutschlands entschieden geschwächt denn
wir können nicht mehr als neutraler
vermittler auftreten und nur noch
eigentlich hoffen dass dieses vorgehen
die diplomatischen wege nicht endgültig
versperrt hat sie intervenieren mit
waffenlieferungen einen fremden krieg
und nennen das werte geleitete
außenpolitik haben sich eigentlich mal
gefragt welche wirkung diese
entscheidung auf unsere partner china
und indien macht wir brauchen
interessengeleitete außenpolitik für
deutschland und europa
die fraktion der alternative für
deutschland im bundestag spricht sich
ganz entschieden gegen die lieferung von
waffen an die ukraine aus waffen haben
kriege noch nie verkürzt und sind keine
humanitären hilfsgütern
die armen und wir müssen unsere
humanitäre hilfe fortführen und ich
meine damit die arbeit die unterstützung
auch von kriegsflüchtlingen wie die
hilfe für die notleidenden vor zum
beispiel durch die lieferung
medizinischer hilfsmittel medikamente
sowie die möglichkeit sauberes wasser
und energie bereitzustellen und viele
hier im plenarsaal an gerade auch die
medien müssen endlich rhetorisch
abrüsten die friedens rhetorik muss in
den vordergrund treten nicht die
kriegsrhetorik
werde kollegen
werte kollegen bitte kommen sie zur
vernunft lassen sie ihre gewissen
entscheiden und stimmen sie gegen die
waffenlieferung an die ukraine die
alternative für deutschland sie ist die
einzige fraktion im deutschen bundestag
die aktiven für den frieden auf dem
kontinent europa
spielen
[Applaus]
der kollegen christian dürr hat das wort
für die fdp fraktion
frau präsidentin fährte kollegen
kollegen seit über zwei monaten herrscht
bereits krieg in der ukraine und damit
gegen einen freien staat gegen freie
menschen gegen die freiheit an sich man
darf nicht müde werden zu sagen dieser
krieg ist mit nichts zu rechtfertigen es
ist ein angriffskrieg russlands gegen
das völkerrecht gegen jegliche humanität
und wir müssen diesen krieg verurteilen
an jedem tag in jeder stunde wird dürfen
uns an die bilder aus der ukraine nicht
gewöhnen meine damit dass
russland zivilisten die flucht aus
umkämpften gebieten die mario pohl nicht
erlaubt ist eine schande und putin muss
wissen die ganze welt sieht die
kriegsverbrechen die die russische seite
täglich begehrt wir werden als
deutschland als westen wir werden die
kriegsverbrecher zur rechenschaft ziehen
diebe kollegen
putin führt krieg gegen die ukraine und
damit gegen die liberale demokratie
deshalb ist es eben auch im
sicherheitspolitischen interesse
deutschlands dass die ukraine diesen
krieg nicht verliert deshalb müssen wir
jetzt alles tun was wir können um die
ukraine bei diesem ziel zu unterstützen
meine damen und herren und dafür steht
der antrag aus der mitte des hauses an
diesem tag
und
herr kollege merz mit gc nicht mit dem
kollegen lars klingbeil das war mir
wichtig vorab zu sagen ich bin dankbar
dafür dass die cdu csu fraktion sich
bereit erklärt hat den antrag des
entwurf der regierungsfraktionen
beizutreten das ist ein wichtiges signal
heute das anerkenne und wertschätze ich
herr kollege merz ich will wo es daran
erinnern
die erste reaktion des kollegen frei war
es glaube ich der sagte dieser antrag
ist zu lang für immer bei der ampel erst
viel zu unkonkret jetzt hat er aus sicht
des fraktions 14 genau die richtige
länge und spricht die richtigen punkte
an ja man kann dazulernen darüber freut
sich die ampel regierungsfraktion herr
kollege merz und ich will ich will eins
dazu sagen weil das thema sondervermögen
hier angesprochen worden ist und es war
gestern thema debatte und das legitim
ist auch hier zum gegenstand zu machen
ich stelle mir eine sekunde vor die
oppositionsfraktionen aus bündnis 90/die
grünen und fdp hätten bei viel kleineren
themen in der vergangenen wahlperiode
wie den digital pakt für schulen oder
dem thema grundsteuer gesagt wir reden
mit den regierungsfraktionen nur unter
der prämisse dass wir keinerlei
abgeordneten mehr in die abstimmung
schicken als zwei drittel mehrheit
fehlen wie kleinteilig wäre das schon
damals bei diesen kleinen themen gewesen
herr merz ich fordere sie auf an dieser
wichtigen stelle weiter debatte um das
sondervermögen ihre strategie zu ändern
im sicherheitspolitischen interessen in
deutschland und gerade auch im interesse
der ukraine herr merz sie müssen ihre
strategie dann endlich sagen dass sie
dabei sein wollen als gesamte cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion kommt doch keine
andere antwort und vor allem ein und
geben herr kollege
meine damen und herren es geht um die
rolle deutschlands in dieser krise und
darum was wir konkret tun können und
gemeinsam mit unseren partner die
ukraine bestmöglich zu unterstützen
vor diesem hintergrund ist es der
richtige schritt waffenlieferung zu
ermöglichen sowohl direkte als auch
indirekte lieferung durch unsere partner
und uns setzt es ist richtig ich will
das aussprechen es ist richtig schwere
waffen in diese lieferung mit
einzubeziehen russland hat die ukraine
überfallen mit einem vielfachen an
militärgerät fünfmal so viele panzer
dreimal so viele aktive soldaten die
ukraine befindet sich in einem krieg auf
offenen boden und es geht um ganz
konkrete gelände gewinnen denn wir haben
gesehen was das bedeutet meine damen und
herren
ist kein einzelfall jeder russische
vorstoß bedeutet dass sich diese
verbrechen wiederholen die lieferung
schwerer waffen ist natürlich las den
ball hat es gesagt keine
selbstverständlichkeit aber es ist jetzt
eine notwendigkeit meine damen und
herren
und
dabei sollten wir
an zwei wir müssen uns orientieren wir
liefern die art waffen die auch andere
verbündete liefern wir liefern was
unsere eigene bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit nicht gefährdet
und deshalb liefern wir jetzt was die
ukraine braucht um das in einen kontext
zu stellen die vereinigten staaten
frankreich
großbritannien und andere haben schon
oder planen die konkrete lieferung
schwerer waffen wir stehen also mit
diesem schritt eng eng an der seite
unserer partner deutschland muss seiner
verantwortung gerecht werden und das
drückt dieser gemeinsame antrag
gemeinsame antrag aus der mitte des
deutschen bundestages heute aus meine
damen und herren
und ich will zum schluss 1 sagen was mir
wichtig ist für präsidentin putin hat
mit seinen angriffskrieg die alte
weltordnung zerrissen das alte kommt
nicht wieder deshalb werden wir auch die
wirtschaftlichen beziehungen mit putins
russland beenden und wir werden die
beziehung zu liberalen demokratien
weltweit stärken deshalb ist es richtig
dass der bundeskanzler
dieser tage nach japan gereist ist um
genau das zu tun auch das will ich an
dieser stelle sagen ich bin dem
bundeskanzler ausdrücklich dankbar dass
er genau das was er genau das
es ist die erste präsidentin es ist ein
wichtiges zeichen dass wir heute einen
antrag beraten der von der großen
demokratischen mitte des hauses getragen
wird und am ende auch beschlossen wird
deutschland meine damen und herren steht
an der seite der ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer
gemeinsam mit seinen verbündeten und
partnern in der welt ich danke ihnen
[Applaus]
die papa das wort für die fraktion die
linke
werde meine damen und herren es klar und
deutlich zu sagen meine fraktion
verurteilt auf das schärfste den
brutalen und völkerrechtswidrigen krieg
den putin führt ohne wenn und aber
meine damen und herren der bundeskanzler
hat am vergangenen wochenende gegenüber
dem spiegel interview gegeben und hat
seinen bisherigen kurs dort verteidigt
keine schweren waffen in die ukraine zu
liefern ich darf seine begründung
zitieren ich tue alles um eine
eskalation zu verhindern die zu einem
dritten weltkrieg führt es darf keinen
atomkrieg gegen millionen menschen in
deutschland haben genau diese sorgen und
ängste und meine fraktion unterstützt
dass ausdrücklich und das sollte auch
nicht nur ihrer politik sein meine daten
unter anderem mit der angst vor kritik
hat der bundeskanzler die lieferung
schwerer waffen ausgeschlossen und zwar
zurecht
und herren und deswegen verstehe ich
überhaupt nicht das 72 stunden später
die verteidigungsminister und das
gegenteil verkündet deutschland liefert
schwere waffen in die ukraine meine
damen und herren das heißt jeden tag
eine kehrtwende ich komme da nicht mehr
mit und es geht vielen menschen in
unserem land so dass sie dann nicht mehr
mitkommen wir leben erleben ein
kommunikations desaster der ampel ist
dass die führung her klingbeil die olaf
scholz versprochen hat und bei die man
bei ihm bestellen kann sie haben die
schattenminister hofreiter und strack
zimmermann die führende parallel
diplomatie das ist die lage der ampel
wenn ich den antrag lese muss ich muss
ich dem bundeskanzler sagen es tut mir
leid die jungs und mädels die haben sich
tatsächlich durchgesetzt das ist die
wahrheit und in ihrem antrag machen sie
jetzt sogar china mit zu einer
konfliktpartei wollen sie wirklich damit
etwa für frieden sorgen wenn sich china
in dem antrag aufhören nein das ist das
gegenteil das tut doch genau das was
andere gewollt habe dass vier tage nach
dem spiegel interview ein antrag
vorliegt der im widerspruch zu seinen
aussagen steht das ist kein ausweis von
führungsstärke das ist das gegenteil
meine damen und ihr ist aber auch zu
ihnen im herzen haben wir hier so
nachträglich
ihre position verteidigt was diese tagen
hier aufgeführt haben das ist ein
schauspiel das hat mit verantwortung
ehrlich gesagt nichts zu tun das ist der
situation völlig unangemessen und im
übrigen schadet das dem ansehen
deutschland weil sie ja genau das
befördern nämlich die spaltung sie haben
die drei doch erpresst mit ihrer
zustimmung zu dem 100 milliarden paket
das ist doch deswegen gibt es doch den
antrag und setzte ihn doch überhaupt
nicht gegeben dass es letztlich putin
spiel ihnen geht es nicht um die ukraine
ihm geht es um profilierung und in
politischen geländegewinn gerade mit
blick auf die wahlen in schleswig
holstein und nordrhein westfalen und das
ist inakzeptabel meine damen und herren
wurde die fragen stellten an welchem
punkt wir denn jetzt eigentlich sind
lieber rolf mützenich sie haben davon
gesprochen völlig zu recht dass es eine
militärische schlag seitigen ja das ist
sogar meines untertrieben es gibt einen
fatalen wettlauf höher schneller weiter
wer liefert die schwersten waffen
glauben sie wirklich irgend wer hier im
hause das mit der lieferung schwerer
waffen dieser krieg beendet wird was ist
denn eigentlich das strategische ziel
von deutschland was ist denn eigentlich
das strategische ziel der ukraine das
wäre doch mal nicht voraussetzung das zu
wissen bevor man liefert warum liefern
eigentlich nicht die amerikaner
modernstes kriegsgerät das müssen sie
doch denn eigentlich machen wenn das so
eindeutig wer nein hier wird viel zu
wenig über diplomatische vorstöße und
initiativen gretel heeres waren moskaus
orientiert das sollte eine rolle spielen
da sollte es unterstützung geben meine
damit dass sie mich willkommen auch die
aussage des bundeskanzlers ich tue alles
um eine eskalation zu verhindern die
einen zu einem dritten weltkrieg führt
es darf keinen atomkrieg geben ja meine
damen und herren das erwarten die
menschen das erwarten die menschen auch
von der bundesregierung und das muss das
oberste ziel sein in dieser dramatischen
entwicklung denn darauf haben sie ihren
amtseid geschworen und ich hoffe dass
das was sie gesagt haben wir hatten
prinzipien klingbeil dass das wirklich
ein versprecher war dieser krieg putins
muss schnellstmöglich enden er darf sich
nicht ausweiten aber solidarität mit der
ukraine mit den menschen ukraine
einerseits die eskalation und jegliche
jegliche diplomatische bemühungen
andererseits das sind zwei seiten einer
medaille
schwere waffen zu liefern bitte das
macht vielen menschen angst meine da und
herren und deswegen werden wir uns auch
dagegen positionieren herzlichen dank
die kollegin der stadt burgau hat das
wort für bündnis 90 die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
jeder und jede von uns mit herz und
verstand will doch nur eins dass diese
blutige gewalt gegen die unschuldigen
menschen in der ukraine endlich sofort
auf
wie viele
deutsche lieber sanktionsdrohung gab es
vor dem 24 februar mit dem ziel diesen
krieg zu verhindern wie viele harte
sanktionen nach dem beginn des
angriffskriegs damit es zu einem ende
der gewalt kommt all das war zwar
richtig und notwendig hat wladimir putin
aber bisher nicht unmittelbar gestoppt
das einzige was ihnen auffällt noch mehr
kriegsverbrechen und verbrechen gegen
die menschlichkeit zu verüben das
einzige was zur befreiung bereits
besetzter gebiete beigetragen hat das
ist der entschiedener und mutige
widerstand der ukraine
die menschen dort verteidigen gerade mit
allem was sie haben ihr land gelegen und
ihre sicherheit angesichts ihres kampfes
für frieden aber auch für unsere
sicherheit stehen auch wir in der
verantwortung
und ja es ist nie eine einfache
entscheidung tödliche waffen zu liefern
das darf es auch nie sein aber in diesen
dramatischen wochen kann und darf es
auch keine falsche zurückhaltung geben
die den brutalen krieg skalp nichts
entgegen zu setzen weiß
lassen sie mich an dieser stelle auch zu
allen sagen die meinen waffenlieferungen
würden diesen krieg verlängert ein
militärischer sieg russlands bedeutet
kein ende der gewalt und keine befreiung
sondern gegenteil
das zeigen die letzten wochen die ganzen
berichte über morde misshandlungen
systematische vergewaltigung und weitere
schwere menschenrechtsverletzungen
bewiesen dafür stehen die toten von
botschaft und an vielen anderen orten in
der ukraine
der plan von präsident putin ist eine
durchsetzung einer imperialer
machtansprüche auf den trümmern der
ukraine mit jeder zerstörten stadt will
er seine position am verhandlungstisch
stärken deshalb ist eine unterstützung
der ukraine mit waffen und allem was
nötig ist auch die voraussetzung dafür
dass dieser krieg am ende auch mit
verhandlungen beendet werden kann die
nicht von russland diktiert werden
wenn eine solche vermeintliche
verhandlungslösung sie würde keinen
frieden sondern nun neue verbrechen
bringen und den weg für weitere
aggression und gewalt in der ukraine und
auf unserem kontinent bangen dass meine
damen und herren sind die gründe warum
viele in diesem hohen haus die
unterstützung mit waffenlieferungen
einer sehr schwierigen abwägung für
richtig halten und ich finde wir haben
heute auch in dieser debatte vielleicht
ein bisschen zu viel darüber gesprochen
wer wie was wo gesagt hat wer wie wo
aufgetreten ist und ich möchte mich ganz
herzlich bei allen kolleginnen und
kollegen in den ampel fraktionen aber
auch bei den kolleginnen und kollegen in
der union die anders aufgetreten sind
anders argumentiert haben als wir das
heute hier erlebt haben bedanken dass es
zu diesem starken zeichen der einigkeit
der solidarität mit der ukraine in
diesen dramatischen zeiten gekommen
in die botschaft ist dass unsere
solidarität mit der ukraine riesig ist
und dass russland diesen krieg mit
seinen verbrechen und seiner brutalität
nicht gewinnen darf mit dem ringtausch
und gelangen mit deutscher unterstützung
schwere waffen schnell in den einsatz
der ukrainischen streitkräfte zu
gleichen müssen mit blick auf die
lieferung moderner und komplexere
systeme die länger brauchen jetzt
entscheidungen und vorbereitungen
getroffen werden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
verständlicherweise ist in den letzten
tagen viel über waffenlieferungen
diskutiert worden es ist eine schwierige
entscheidung aber es wäre es zeit dass
deutsche europäische engagement allein
auf die frage von waffenlieferungen zu
reduzieren es gehört so viel mehr dazu
eine diplomatie die alles für ein ende
der gewalt und das system putin iso und
international isoliert alles mögliche
was wir tun können um das leid der
menschen zu lindern von der erhöhung der
humanitären hilfe bis zur psychosozialen
versorgung dass frauen die
vergewaltigung erlitten haben die
vorbereitung weiterer sanktionen die
aufklärung und verfolgung von
kriegsverbrechen und verbrechen gegen
die menschlichkeit die finanzielle
unterstützung der ukraine und eine
politische perspektive in der
europäischen union wie wir sie auch in
unserem antrag geschrieben
ebenso gewahrt die rückversicherung dass
schutz unserer mittel und
osteuropäischen partnerinnen und partner
aber auch der skandinavischen mit dazu
eine entwicklungszusammenarbeit die
versucht die folgen für den globalen
süden ab zumindest und besonders auf
eine energiepolitik die abhängigkeiten
verwundbarkeiten aber auch unseren
beitrag zur finanzierung des kreml
regimes massiv reduziert minister habe
vorgestern angekündigt das dach der
bereits drastischen reduzierung der
abhängigkeit von russischem öl in den
letzten wochen nun ein sehr billiger und
deutlich schnellerer ausstieg möglich
ist und das ist ein sehr wichtiger
schritt von großer tragweite
meine damen und herren all das gehört zu
einem umfassenden ansatz dazu und am
ende zählt was wir tun dass unsere
bundesregierung weiter entschlossen kann
wird denn die menschen in der ukraine
brauchen in diesen düsteren zeiten alle
unterstützung die wir geben können
vielen dank
der kollege johann wadephul hat jetzt
das wort polizei suchen
[Applaus]
sehr verehrten damen und herren spät
kommt hier doch hier kommt möchte ich
den kolleginnen und kollegen der ampel
koalition entgegen rufen macht uns
möglich heute dem antrag zuzustimmen
wir stimmen dem antrag zu weil sie die
gretchenfrage die die geschichte
deutschland heute stellt richtig
beantworten deutschland steht
entschlossen an der seite der ukraine
und liefert schwere waffen
wir stehen zusammen und hier wird schon
die gemeinsamkeit der demokraten und
demokraten hier in der mitte des hauses
und das tun wir
gerne das tun wir voller überzeugung und
insofern schließt sich an viele
äußerungen
der rednerinnen und redner der
koalitionsfraktionen hier an es ist
wichtig gerade in dieser zeit dass
deutschland ein bild der geschlossenheit
zeigt wir werfen putin diesen
angriffskrieg diesen vernichtungskrieg
nicht durchgehen lassen deutschland
steht geschlossen an der seite der
ukraine geschlossen an der seite der
alliierten die die ukraine hier
unterstützen und das ein signal der
humanität der menschlichkeit ein signal
für freiheit und für die friedensordnung
in europa das wichtig ist
und deswegen
deswegen
kollege bartsch will ich schon kollegen
der afg braucht man gar nicht darauf
eingehen sagen wir haben ein
strategisches ziel dabei und europa das
zusammensteht hat ein strategisches ziel
wir wollen putin stoppen wir wollen
nicht zu sehen wir einen genozid begeht
wie frauen vergewaltigt werden die
zivilisten getötet werden wie
flächenbombardements vorgenommen werden
und wie hier die friedensordnung europas
in einer art und weise zerstört wie wir
es uns vor weniger zeit nicht habe
vorstellen können und ich glaube das
wäre eigentlich ein ziel wo auch eine
linke partei
die ja mal auch den anspruch hatte für
frieden und völkerverständigung
einzustehen wo auch eine linke partei
darüber nachdenken sollte ob sie an
dieser stelle nicht wirklich auch an der
seite der freien ukraine stehen sollte
aus meiner sicht wäre das angebracht
ich halte es auch für richtig ist wird
deutsche bundestag darüber entscheidung
bin froh dass der deutsche bundestag
darüber entscheidet
manch eine äußerung als wir den antrag
angekündigt haben aus den reihen der
koalition habe ich nicht ganz verstanden
das sei parteipolitik grad von der fdp
parteipolitische ist boden tun dabei
haben wir doch ihren antrag den sie auf
dem bundesparteitag ein ziemlich
verabschiedet haben hier nur zur geltung
gebracht meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren stellen wir unser licht nicht
unter den scheffel nein es ist eine
schwierige ist eine abwägungsfrage aber
dass eine derartige frage ob deutschland
schwere waffen liefert gerade vom
höchsten beschlussgremium in einer
parlamentarischen demokratie auch
getroffen wird das muss doch alle
demokraten alle parlamentarier hier ein
das muss es uns doch wert dann ist doch
richtig dass der deutsche bundestag
darüber entscheidet
gut dass ihr deutschen bundestag darüber
entscheidet
und das will ich in allem respekt sagen
ich bin ein großer freund japans und es
ist richtig dass der bundeskanzler dahin
reist aber ich sage ihnen auch in dieser
historischen situation nach einer langen
osterpause nach dieser schwierigen
entscheidung wo er selber die frage
aufgeworfen hat ob es nicht einen
atomkrieg
hervorrufen könnte da ist es wäre es die
nicht nur das bag gegenüber dem hohen
hause gewesen sondern da wäre es seine
verantwortung als bundeskanzler olaf
scholz gewesen deutschland und er ist
der kanzler dieses landes und der welt
zu erklären warum diese entscheidung
getroffen wird sie haben von einer
staatspolitischen rede gesprochen
erklingen bei die staatspolitische rede
hätte heute hier der bundeskanzler
halten müssen der wäre hier gefordert
gewesen den hätten wir hier sehen wollen
und wenn sie sagen erst das land
erst das land unter an andere dinge dann
gilt das für alle und ich habe großen
respekt vor menschen die früher diese
regierung geführt haben aber dass
gerhard schröder sagt erst mein konto
und dann alles andere das ist ihre
aufgabe als parteivorsitzender der
aufzuräumen und dafür zu sorgen dass
trust beendet
dankeschön
herr kollege dr nils schmid hat das wort
für die spd
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren
schade schade erwartet gut es war so
eine gute rede bis zu bis auf ihrem
schluss
und ich will noch mal eins noch mal
sagen wegen der reise des bundeskanzlers
nach japan
japan ist in asien der wichtigste werte
port vor deutschlands g7 mitglied wir
haben alle gemeinsam die letzte
bundesregierung dazu beglückwünscht eine
indopazifik strategie verabschiedet zu
haben
deshalb ist es gut dass die erste
asienreise des neuen bundeskanzlers olaf
scholz gerade nach japan geht und dass
wir damit auch ein deutliches signal
setzen wie wichtig uns ja japan und
asien insgesamt ist genauso wie ich ist
es wichtig dass die deutsch indischen
regierungskonsultationen
demnächst stattfinden und deshalb stehen
wir voll hinter dieser reise auch zu
diesem zeitpunkt ein damm
und historische und staatspolitische
reden kann man halten und im unterschied
zur unionsfraktion hat der kanzler mit
der zeitenwende regierungserklärung dies
schon geradezu bereinigt konflikt getan
und dass wir jetzt auf der strecke
hier im deutschen bundestag noch einmal
gemeinsam klar ziehen dass wir hinter
der ukraine hinter dem ukrainischen volk
stehen dass wir dazu einen gemeinsamen
antrag verabschieden ist ein unglaublich
starkes zeichen und ich will dann doch
helfen insbesondere noch mal danken dass
er diese gemeinsamkeit heraus gestrichen
hat und setze darauf dass für die dauer
des konfliktes des krieges aber auch für
die langjährige auseinandersetzung mit
einem aggressiven russland unter putin
dass diese gemeinsamkeit möglichst lange
erhalten bleibt wenn es auch ein gutes
zeichen dass die union jetzt dem
koalitionsantrag beitritt ihn
unterstützt wir haben sechs wörter
verändert aber ansonsten ist der
umfassende antrag der drei ampel
parteien die grundlage dieser
gemeinsamen breiten beschlussfassung
damit schließlich auch die union einem
umfassenden sicherheitsbegriff an wo es
eben nicht nur um waffenlieferungen geht
sondern auch in die internationale
ordnung die verteidigung des
völkerrechts die strafverfolgung von
kriegsverbrechen die auswirkungen auf
globale ernährungssicherheit die rolle
chinas in diesem konflikt all das ist in
diesen antrag zu recht aufgegriffen
worden und im ergebnis
unterstützt diese antrag die sorgfältig
abwägen der politik der bundesregierung
des bundeskanzlers und deshalb sind
jegliche vorwürfe das zaudern und
führungsschwäche zu tage treten völlig
fehl am platz mit diesem antrag sind
diese vorwürfe hinfällig geworden eines
der ferne
und mit diesem antrag bekennt sich die
große mehrheit des deutschen bundestages
auch zu den zwei tragenden prinzipien
der politik deutschlands
während des krieges russlands gegen die
ukraine die erste linie ist von der nato
schon sehr frühzeitig vor ausbruch des
krieges festgelegt worden die nato und
damit auch deutschland wird nicht
kriegspartei das ist ein leitprinzip das
auch jeden schritt diese bundesregierung
leitet und das zweite prinzip ist putin
darf diesen krieg nicht gewinnen
deshalb unterstützen wir diese freiheit
mit allem was wir haben politisch
diplomatisch ökonomisch und natürlich
auch sehr wohl abgewogen militärisch
natürlich wollen wir alle möglichst bald
ein ende des krieges aber
das sage ich auch richtung linkspartei
nicht um den preis dass der accessoire
gewinnt denn putin darf diesen krieg
nicht gewinnen meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren und deshalb ist eben
jeder schritt auch der waffenlieferung
sorgfältig abzuwägen mit dem blick auf
die möglichkeit der eskalation und auf
die möglichkeit dass die nato doch
kriegspartei werden könnte und deshalb
ist auch kein drehbuch vorhanden gibt es
nicht eine einfache wahrheit in den
diskussionen die wir führen und deshalb
ist es so wichtig dass sehr vorsichtig
sehr ausgewogen entschieden wird durch
diejenigen die die verantwortung tragen
an erster linie die bundesregierung und
wir müssen das dilemma aus halten
dass der krieg erst dann und dann
besonders schnell zu ende geht wenn die
ukraine militärisch in die lage versetzt
wird eine kapitulation gegenüber putin
zu verhindern manager broker hat es
angesprochen es ist ein paradox auch ein
dilemma das ein schnelles ende des
krieges voraussetzt erstmal waffen zu
liefern wie die ukraine überhaupt in
eine verhandlungsposition kommt dass
putin nicht einseitig das in des krieges
diktieren können damit müssen wir
umgehen das müssen wir aushalten
das ist schwierig aber fern darunter und
deshalb ist es auch so wichtig dass bei
den militärischen entscheidung so
sorgfältig abgewogen wird und damit
komme ich zum schluss sein bitte an uns
alle nicht nur an uns im parlament
sondern auch an die deutsche
gesellschaft und die medien an die
social media welt
diese debatte trägt uns um dieser trick
treffen sollen wir wollen die ukraine
helfen aber es gibt eben keine einfachen
lösungen man kann nicht heute mal die
waffe aus dem internet ziehen und sagen
sie muss geliefert werden und morgen die
anderen es ist eine wirklich wirklich
schwere und auch neuartige debatte in
deutschland in keinem anderen nato land
wird öffentlich über die details von
waffen liefern so ausgiebig diskutiert
wie in deutschland
nein das hat nichts mit zögern zu tun so
das hat etwas damit zu tun dass uns
umtreibt und das ist nicht einfach ist
meine sehr verehrten damen und gerade
weil es nicht einfach ist verbietet es
sich auch nur einfach in twitter oder
auch medial zu meinen das ist die einzig
der einzig mögliche weg und deshalb
wünsche ich mir dass wir manche
stilblüte manche überschießende von drei
ende der debatte in zukunft vermeiden
und dass wir mit heißem herzen und
kühlem kopf diese debatte führen genauso
wie der grund ist ganz was tut meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren
herzlichen dank
für die fdp fraktion spricht dr anzünder
golland
präsidentin meine damen und herren es
ist immer ein undankbares geschäft nach
erklärungen für ein verhalten zu suchen
dass frauen und kinder tötet und städte
in schutt und asche legt und wenn es
außerdem noch um freiheit demokratie und
westliche werte geht muss man in einem
land wie deutschland
auf der richtigen seite der geschichte
stehen die moral schlägt immer die
geopolitik wissen wir doch seit langem
dass die nato ein verteidigungsbündnis
ist und putin wenn er nicht angst vor
der freiheit hätte die nato nicht zu
fürchten bräuchte so einfach so
unterkomplex denn es kommt eben nicht
auf unserer einschätzung der nato an
sondern auf die russische sicht und
erleben die russen seit der deutschen
wiedervereinigung ein unaufhaltsame sfor
rücken eines ihnen entgegen gesetzten
militärbündnisses gegen die russischen
grenzen
meine damen und herren es ist nicht nur
eine auseinandersetzung zwischen
autokratie und demokratie sondern auch
ein zusammen ball politischer
militärischer und wirtschaftlicher
interessen und deshalb ist es auch
falsch diesen konflikt mit schweren
waffen anzuheizen
[Applaus]
so der frühere militär berater angela
merkels erich fahrt jede militärische
lösung führt in die katastrophe
wenn deutsche politiker und heute ist es
wieder geschehen postulieren russland
darf nicht gewinnen muss man deshalb
hinzufügen es darf auch nicht verlieren
da eine atommacht auch in einem krieg
nach art des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
die mittel des zwanzigsten und
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts einsetzen
kann wenn sie droht zu unterlegen und
das wollen sie hoffentlich auch nicht im
falle russland kommt ein weiteres
dilemma hin zu
völkerrechtlich normierte ordnungen
haben sich in der geschichte nur dann
als haltbar erwiesen wenn die
unterlegene seite gleichberechtigt
eingebunden war bestes historisches
beispiel ist die wiener ordnung von 1815
nach dem sieg über napoleon in dem
frankreich eine gleichberechtigte rolle
spielen konnte vermieden die akteure von
wien eine dauernde revolutionären
unzufriedenheit des besiegten das ganze
gegenteil davon war es ein 19 19 und
genau das meine damen und herren ist
heute das problem russlands es hat die
einseitigen veränderungen nach 1989
innerlich nie wirklich akzeptiert sie
wären besser im zusammenwirken mit
russland und nicht gegen eine unter
jelzin vorübergehend geschwächte macht
durchgesetzt worden ich vergleiche
hinken immer
die nato osterweiterung war aber mehr
wert sei als wie das hat ein schwaches
russland beschlägt jetzt wo in der
ukraine der kern des zarenreiches wie
der sowjetunion tangiert wird sehen die
russischen eliten eine rote linie
überschritten
solange russland großmacht und atommacht
ist werden abmachungen nur reißfest sein
wenn sie das land innerlich mit trägt
eine westliche ukraine ist es nicht
folglich kann nur ein kompromiss nur ein
kompromiss aber nicht der sieg der einen
oder anderen seite diesen krieg beenden
die lieferung schwerer waffen ist dazu
kein sinnvoller beitrag möchte da an
sich und englisch basische initiative
deutschlands wäre sehr viel sinnvoller
und wichtiger ich bin angemessen
das wort hat die kollegin doppel maria
zimmermann für die fdp
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
ich zitiere der organisierung des
friedens stehen starke kräfte entgegen
wir haben erfahren in welchem bereich
der mensch zurückfallen kann keine
religion keine ideologie keine
glanzvolle entfaltet kultur schließt mit
sicherheit aus dass aus den seelischen
tiefenschichten der menschenhass
hervorbrechen und völker ins unheil
reißen kann der frieden ist so wenig wie
die freiheit ein urzustand den wir
vorfinden wir müssen ihn machen im
wahrsten sinne des wortes das sagte
willy brandt als er 1971 den
friedensnobelpreis in oslo entgegen nahm
heute meine damen und herren
gespenstisch aktuell er sorgte sich
bereits seinerzeit um die zukunft
europas und deutete die verantwortung
deutschlands
51 jahre später werden wir brutal von
diesem szenario eingeholt vor 63 tagen
über vier russland die ukraine mordet
und brandschatzen und greift damit auch
aller unserer regeln und werte basierte
ordnung an meine damen und herren eine
ordnung die 1945 als konsequenz aus dem
barbarischen zweiten weltkrieg erwuchs
nie wieder sollte das prinzip des
stärkeren gelten die vereinten nationen
wurden gegründet um künftige
geschlechter vor der geißel des krieges
zu bewahren auf diese charta konnten
sich seit jahrzehnten weltweit alle
staaten berufen und diese gewissheit ist
seit dem 24
februar zerstört und die erosion
meine damen und herren die auch erosion
dieses werteverfalls nahm vor vielen
jahren seinen anfang die warnzeichen
waren da und die annexion der trimm
bereits brutale realität
das weißbuch wurde erneuert und die
landes- und bündnisverteidigung in den
vordergrund gestellt um dann sagen die
es ganz deutlich naiv ignorant in
deutscher ruhe dabei zuzusehen wie
russland bereits vor acht jahren ein
krieg in der ost ukraine anzettelte
meine damen und herren
14.000 menschen sind seitdem ums leben
gekommen es geht um freiheit und
demokratie um selbstbestimmung um
menschenrechte die mit den füßen
getreten werden und deshalb bittet
deshalb ruft ja deshalb schreibt die
ukraine nach unserer hilfe und das mag
manchen tierisch auf den keks gehen wir
sollten aber solange bereit sein dazu
stehen so lange ist die vollständige
territoriale integrität der ukraine
wieder hergestellt ist meine damen und
herren
der
vorliegende antrag ist daher unser
codecs wie dir darauf gemeinsam über
parteigrenzen hinweg als
abgeordnete aber vor allem als menschen
reagieren aus der mitte des parlaments
heraus die vergangenen wochen meine
damen und herren waren für uns alle eine
immense herausforderung
der in deutschland aufgewachsen ist
kennt keinen krieg das ist der
wunderbare teil der geschichte wie man
dem krieg begegnet sorgte auch deswegen
für knallharte diskussion und ich bin
sehr froh dass unsere bundesregierung
eingebettet im westlichen bündnis den
hat hat auch schwere waffen an die
ukraine zu liefern und dieses hätte
willy brandt wie folgt eingeordnet er
sagte es 1970 nichts kommt von selbst
und nur wenige ist von dauer darum sind
euch auf eure kraft und darauf dass jede
zeit eigene an offen will man auf ihrer
höhe zu sein hat wenn gutes bewirkt
werden soll
[Applaus]
marie agnes strack zimmermann die
vorsitzende des verteidigungsausschusses
und in den letzten wochen ja immer
wieder sich zu wort gemeldet als an
vehement ehesten befürworterinnen für
die lieferung schwerer waffen thomas
ernte hören wir jetzt am rednerpult für
die union
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen finde es gut
dass wir uns auch diesen gemeinsamen
antrag geeinigt haben wir hätten
sicherlich manches direkter stringenter
formuliert aber es ist wichtig dass
koalition und union hier gemeinsam
vorangehen eines ist klar die ukraine
braucht die größtmögliche unterstützung
unseres landes und da ist es wichtig
dass eine mehrheit im deutschen
parlament ein starkes signal der
verantwortung sendet und sich
entschieden hinter das land stellt das
brutal angegriffen wurde
war es aber auch meine damen und herren
dass es ohne die unionsfraktion heute
weder diese debatte noch den antrag
gegeben hätte und dass es womöglich auch
keine bewegung bei der lieferung
schwerer waffen geben hätte es hat er
möglicherweise weitere nur streit in der
koalition und ein zaudern und zögern
ganz speziell im kanzleramt das sind die
fakten und das unterstreicht wie wichtig
eine konstruktive opposition ist meine
damen und herren
ein paar worte an die spd gerichtet sie
können natürlich öffentlich und
taktische spielchen vorwerfen weil sie
können hier parteipolitik kritisieren
und trotzdem eine parteipolitische rede
halten oder herr mützenich vor einer
militaristischen debatte waren ich finde
das ist ein völlig absurder und
unerträglicher ausfall gewiesen oder sie
können uns wie der cunard als sich nur
an taub tun weil der die anwesenheit des
kanzlers im parlament fordern kann man
alles machen was sie aber auch tun
können und das fände ich wesentlich
sinnvoller wäre es sich besser mit ihrem
kanzler abzustimmen denn dann würden
nämlich nicht morgens sie öffentlich das
gegenteil von dem erzählen was kanzler
und verteidigungsministerin wenig später
entscheiden und verkünden so wie wir das
bei der freigabe der gepard lieferung
der fall war meine damen und herren
liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
der kanzler reist heute zum geburtstag
der deutschen handelskammer nach tokio
kann man machen japan ist natürlich ein
wichtiger partner aber der bundeskanzler
war nicht in kiew er war nicht im
baltikum nicht in tschechien der
slowakei oder in rumänien bei den
nachbarn die zutiefst irritiert und
enttäuscht sind von der zögerlichkeit
dieses bundeskanzlers bei den nachbarn
die ihn von ihren ängsten berichten
könnten vom trauma der russischen
herrschaft über ihre gesellschaften
nachbarn die wirklich alles tun damit
die ukraine diesen krieg gewinnen
müssen dass sie die nächsten sein können
wenn putin nicht in der ukraine gestoppt
wird hier läge es gibt den wunsch nach
einer zwischenfrage
wieso ihn dort wären wichtige signale
gewesen das hätten die reiseziele in
diesen tagen sein müssen meine damen und
herren das hätte ich vom regierungschef
des größten europäischen landes erwartet
ohne kette sind so einer krise wirkliche
führung erwartet denn wer vorausschauend
führt argumentiert nicht mit punkten die
er kurz darauf immer wieder einkassieren
muss wer umsichtig führt betreibt keine
angst bahrain und wer immer als letzter
eine entscheidung trifft meine damen
handelt nicht im verbund mit partnern
sondern muss von verbündeten immer erst
bedrängt werden bis endlich etwas
passiert
meine damen und herren die zeitenwende
darf nicht nur eine rhetorische griff
bleiben es braucht jetzt schwere waffen
für die ukraine und die regierung hat
mit diesem antrag die rückendeckung des
parlaments das ist wichtig aber für uns
ist damit eine klare erwartungshaltung
verbunden liefern was geht auch die
japaner einst auch die marder
perspektivisch modernere systeme keine
ausreden keine verzögerungen mehr und
die entscheidung für den gp hat darf
jetzt kein ruhigstellen des parlaments
und unserer partner sein und ich hoffe
wirklich dass
dieses system auch eingesetzt werden
kann am ende geht es nicht darum dass
wir uns bemüht haben dass wir auch was
geliefert haben es geht einzig und
allein darum dass das ziel erreicht wird
nämlich dass russland militärisch in
ukraine nicht erfolgreich sein darf dort
werden wir sie bessern zum ende kommen
zum ende der präsident den daran werden
wir sie messen und daran wird diese
bundesregierung auch voller geschichte
gemessen werden deshalb beherzt handeln
statt zaudern herzlichen dank
thomas ertl war das für die
cdu/csu-fraktion und jetzt haben wir
ihnen dieser debatte
noch ein redner aber es gibt auch noch
die zeit und die möglichkeit für eine
kurzintervention klaus ernst für die
linke also meine damen und herren wir
diskutieren hier auch der kanzler nach
japan fährt oder nicht von der union
kommen sind solche diskussionen ich
glaube uns ist gar nicht klar was wir
hier gerade beschließen
und die diskutieren eine reise eines
kanzlers der kanzler hat vor kurzem
einen wichtigen satz gesagt ja gesagt da
müssen beachten dass möglicherweise das
wort ist bereits zitierte spiegel
interview dass wir möglicherweise auf
eine weitere militärische eskalation
auch einen auf einen atomkrieg zu gehen
könnten ich lese gerade bisher schwere
waffen ausgeschlossen und jetzt frage
ich sie alle insbesondere herrn merz
also ich würde sagen ja wer ich bin ja
froh dass die kanzlerin uns dort
beigetragen hat dass wir uns einige
jahre erspart geblieben sind aber ich
hatte aber ich aber ich habe jetzt den
eindruck mit dem was wir hier tun möchte
ich sie auch mal fragen sind eher den
nun eine atomare auseinandersetzung in
dieser welt wird diesen beschluss den
wir heute erfassen näher oder sind wir
weiter weg
und ich sage ihnen wir sind mit jedem
schritt den wir hier weiter in richtung
eskalieren dem atomkrieg und der
weiteren auseinandersetzung mehr als
vorher da sind wir als vorher und
deshalb sagt und deshalb wundert mich
mit welcher fragen sie sich beschäftigen
mit reisen des kanzlers mein gott was
reden wir denn hier eigentlich wir reden
über die frage ob er hier in einem
halben jahr oder in einem jahr noch
durch ein berlin gehen können das nicht
zerstört ist weil wenn es einen
atomkrieg sind sind ja auch betroffen
bei den damen und herren und ich würde
mich freuen wenn wir hier wenigstens ein
wenig darüber reden könnten welche
vorschläge wir haben den krieg zu
beenden oder zusätzliche militarisierung
herr merz
unglaublich was wir hier machen
die antwort jetzt kann der kollege
angegeben wenn er möchte bitteschön
vielen dank frau präsidentin ist es ja
auch interessant damen applaus zu sehen
von welchen zeiten die zustimmung zu
ihrer einlassung kommt herr kollege
es sind in der tat
wichtige fragestellungen die sie
aufwerfen und deswegen ist ganz klar die
situation so dass wir hier vom
bundeskanzler erwartet hätten dass sie
diese debatte auch anzusprechen und zu
erklären es ist weder die reise
angemessen in diesen tagen wenn diese
fragen auf dem tisch liegen noch ist es
angemessen die erklärung über das
regierungshandeln über möglicherweise
meinungs- änderungen in einem spiegel
interview kund zu tun sondern hier im
parlament wäre der ort wo der
bundeskanzler das machen hätte sollen
und das ist unsere position und deswegen
haben wir das auch hier richtigerweise
angesprochen dankeschön
für die spd fraktion gebe ich jetzt das
wort dem kollegen dr
und er ist der letzte hier zur
aussprache bevor dann ja auch über die
gemeinsamen antrag abgestimmt werden
soll
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine damen und herren die
dramatischen opferzahlen des russischen
überfalls auf die ukraine die getöteten
menschen die aushungerung der
zivilbevölkerung mario pohl und an
anderen orten werden wir in diesem haus
niemals hinnehmen und deswegen ist es
richtig dass koalition und cdu csu
opposition in dieser zeit besonnen und
gemeinsam vorgehen dann ist das teil
dann ist es zeit für abwägen des
handelns die menschen stehen hinter der
ruhigen und unaufgeregten politik des
bundeskanzlers die menschen wollen nicht
dass wir kriegspartei werden und ich
sage mal in richtung auf die linken was
wir eben gehört haben wir würden uns
alle sehr viel wohler fühlen uns wäre
besser für dieses land wird die
moralische empörung der linken auch mit
der bereitschaft in einherginge
verantwortung zu übernehmen in dieser
zeit und diesem antrag zuzustimmen
meine damen und herren olaf scholz führt
dieses land dazu in die richtige
richtung und dafür dass auf die richtige
weise und ich sage das wo er führt es
nicht nur wenn er auf diesem stuhl
sitzen sondern er führt das auch wenn er
mit den wichtigsten verbündeten die wir
auf dieser welt haben engen kontakt hält
den die brauchen wir noch in der zukunft
bei damen und herren die linie der
koalition zur waffenlieferung ist
eindeutig wir liefern das was wir
verfügbar haben wir liefern das was wir
entbehren können ohne die sicherheit und
die bündnis zusagen deutschlands zu
gefährden und wir liefern das was der
ukraine in ihrer schwierigen situation
unmittelbar und nachhaltig hilft ihr
selbstverteidigungsrecht wahrzunehmen
was das jeweils konkret bedeutet
definierenden ersten beiden punkten wir
und im letzten punkt natürlich der
ukraine und dabei gibt es keine
vorbehalte beim material darauf haben
wir uns diese woche mit unseren
alliierten in ramstein geeinigt das
signal von rammstein ist eindeutig es
gibt dieser frage keine alleingänge
sondern wir handeln eng abgestimmt mit
unseren partnern und wir sind in unserer
bundesverteidigungsminister in christine
lambrecht außerordentlich dankbar dass
die metro ihr engagement zu diesem
schulterschluss beigetragen hat
herzlichen dank
liebe kolleginnen kollegen in dieser
schwierigen situation ist die nato nicht
die bedrohung sondern das große arsenal
der freiheit und der demokratie
aber dieses arsenal der freiheit hat
mehr zu bieten als nur waffenlieferungen
die nato ist eine wertegemeinschaft
deren anziehungskraft weiter zunimmt wie
das interesse von schweden und finnland
an einer mitgliedschaft zeigt die nato
repräsentiert zugleich die größte
wirtschaftliche kraft auf dieser welt
das die die wir gemeinsam mit der eu
einsetzen um russland das hohe risiko
für die eigene zukunft klar zu machen
und die nato ihre mitglieder haben auch
eine kulturelle strahlkraft die
russlands repressiven staatsmodell weit
überlegen ist die freiheit des wortes
dagegen kann russland auf dauer keine
barrieren errichten deswegen ist es
beispielsweise auch richtig dass der
gemeinsame antrag ausdrücklich die
deutsche welle als stimme der freiheit
stärkt und auch darüber hinaus jeder
cent den wir die auswärtige kultur und
bildungspolitik stecken ist auch ein
schritt zur eindämmung von
desinformation von russland und in der
welt
diese zahl ist zeigt uns
waffenlieferungen werden gebraucht zur
verteidigung der ukraine aber der weg
zur sicherheit und frieden führt eben
auch über andere pfade
deswegen müssen wir uns stets die frage
stellen was unser gemeinsames ziel ist
eins ist klar
russland auf diesen krieg nicht gewinnen
aber wie kann er enden da darf sich die
diskussion nicht auf die vorstellung
verengen russland militärischen der
ukraine komplett zu besiegen und zur
kapitulation zu bringen das ist eine
strategie mit hohem risiko die
politische lösung dagegen ist völlig
klar wir brauchen im einklang mit dem
un-generalsekretär und der mehrheit der
weltgemeinschaft einen sofortigen
waffenstillstand
umgehende humanitäre hilfe und einen
friedensschluss
wir brauchen liebe kolleginnen kollegen
eine diplomatische lösung auch wenn sich
bei allen demokratisch gesinnten
mitgliedern dieses hauses der magen
umdreht bei der vorstellung dass die
ukraine mit putin verhandeln muss um
ihre souveränität unabhängigkeit und
territorialen unverletzlichkeit zu
sichern aber es wird am ende nicht
anders gehen und deswegen ist ein großes
und richtiges signal dass deutschland
bereit ist für diesen fall dauerhaft die
sicherheit der ukraine mit zu
garantieren ich danke ihnen
[Applaus]
ich schieße damit die aussprache und wir
kommen zur abstimmung über den antrag
der fraktion spd cdu/csu bündnis 90/die
grünen und fdp auf drucksache 15 50 mit
dem titel frieden und freiheit in europa
verteidigen umfassende unterstützung für
die ukraine es lägen einige erklärungen
nach § 31 der geschäftsordnung vor die
sie nachher im protokoll wiederfinden
können die fraktion der afg hat
namentliche abstimmung verlangt die
abstimmung erfolgt in der west lobby sie
haben nach zur abgabe ihrer stimme nach
der eröffnung der abstimmung 20 minuten
zeit bitte gehen sie daher nicht alle
gleichzeitig zur abstimmung
ich bitte die schriftführerin und
schriftführer die plätze an den
abstimmungs ohne nein zu nehmen
das ist bereits der fall dafür danke ich
damit eröffne ich die namentliche
abstimmung jetzt
ja und die bundestags vizepräsidentin
katrin göring eckardt hat das noch
einmal erklärt die abstimmung die
namentliche die findet hier wie in den
letzten anderthalb zwei jahren üblich
auf den früheren hier im reichstag statt
in der westlb- ganz genau gesagt das hat
natürlich immer noch den grund dass man
möglichst abstand halten kann und sollte
wäre der abstimmung nicht alle
abgeordneten auf einmal zu den urnen
gehen
deswegen ist die abstimmung auch
eigentlich 20 minuten geöffnet
und dann wird danach ausgezählten das
ergebnis mitgeteilt also dieser
gemeinsame antrag von den
koalitionsfraktionen und der
cdu/csu-fraktion
beinhaltet sozusagen die unterstützung
der bundesregierung für ihren schritt
der diese woche angekündigt worden ist
auch schwere waffen in die ukraine zu
liefern beispielsweise aus industrie
beständen aber vor allem ist darin auch
festgehalten
dass die bundesregierung auch weiterhin
einen sogenannten ringtausch
unterstützt also nato partner wie
beispielsweise slowenien und dass es
jetzt bereits geplant die panzer so wird
ua bauart an die ukraine abgeben der
bestände sollen dann aufgefüllt werden
mit waffen aus deutschland
dieser antrag den es hier gibt der
insgesamt 40 punkte formuliert mit
forderungen an die bundesregierung der
hat keine bindende wirkung das ist hier
keine gesetzgebung und über
waffenlieferungen beziehungsweise auch
über die möglichkeit zu exporten darüber
entscheidet die bundesregierung
insbesondere der bundessicherheitsrat
aber das soll hier ein starkes signal
sein von den antrag tragenden fraktionen
zumindest wie das in der debatte
mehrfach betont wurde als unterstützung
an die ukraine in ihrem kampf gegen
russland und gegen diesen russischen
angriffskrieg und deswegen gab es auch
eine verständigung erst gestern
nachmittag zwischen den
koalitionsfraktionen und der
unionsfraktion dass man jedoch gemeinsam
diesen antrag macht denn eigentlich
lagen mal zwei unterschiedliche vor
ursprünglich ist dieser
tagesordnungspunkt sowieso nur
aufgesetzt worden weil die cdu csu
fraktion einen sehr weitergehenden
antrag ein weitgehendere antrag hier
aufgesetzt hatte mit der forderung an
die bundesregierung schwere waffen zu
liefern auch beispielsweise
kampfpanzer eventuell sogar aus den
beständen der bundeswehr
zu der ist wie gesagt zurückgezogen
worden weil man hier dieses gemeinsame
signal setzen wollte auch wenn die
debatte alles andere als harmonisch
verlaufen ist friedrich merz der
fraktionschef der nutzer ja die ukraine
debatte durchaus zu einem generalangriff
auf den kanzler der spd-parteichef lars
klingbeil warf märz dank
parteipolitische profilierung vor aber
da schwebt im hintergrund natürlich mit
noch sozusagen die verhandlung über das
100 milliarden euro paket sondervermögen
für die bundeswehr das derzeit in der
parlamentarischen beratung ist